it's time for some day baseball here
at coolers field seven game home stand
wrapping up the rockies are four and two
looking to build and win their fourth
straight series they're trying to do
that with a win today against the san
francisco giants after dropping a
one-run loss
kyle freeland has the baseball for the
third time this year and as we were
discussing a little while ago the first
two have been terrific
here's slater here's the 3-2
and strike three you talk about coming
all the way back that's what kyle just
did
first three out of the zone next three
in the zone and a nice start as he fans
austin slater
so solano steps up
[Music]
hits this one the other way and moving
back is blackman
still moving back and it carries away
from blackman
out into right center field and solano
has got
a double tyler anderson former number
one pick of the rockies
out of the university of oregon back in
2000 2011.
here's story
and that's going to be a base hit right
center field good piece of hitting it is
a great example of why
trevor is going to hit 300. 37 year old
pence back with the giants
after playing with the rangers last year
and having a terrific
season particularly in the first half of
the year he hits it up the middle behind
second grab by garrett hampson a long
throw to first and they got him
good play by garrett hamson showing his
range in armed strength
to get hunter pence
it's a comebacker kyle is going to turn
it the right way right up the middle
well done
he helps himself immensely with his
ability to feel
matt kemp leads it off for the rockies
here in the bottom of the second
hit out into right center field is
dubois is the ball starting to carry
and dubai makes the catch nice play
mauricio dubon that took on some
personality but
that's always been the live part of this
ballpark right center
now ryan mcmahon's the wind up the pitch
and a swinging strike three a cutter
down on the outside first strikeout for
tyler anderson garrett hamson
got him and that'll end the inning two
strikeouts in the in for anderson
the cleanup man for san francisco
to left field coming on it's matt kemp
what a play yeah the former gold glover
center feels it oh bad first ball i get
it
in a year it's not it's a humpback liner
a tough play as tough as you can get for
an outfielder
1-1 on rough and a ground ball toward
nolan he's got
it he spins he throws wow
pretty good comes charlie blackman
this is loop to left stay fair it will
charlie is going to hold up
that's now a 10 game hit streak for
charlotte
donovan solano coming up with two outs
solano lines it to left a base hit
his second hit of the game and that's
going to get longoria a shot
line drive what a catch by hanson
and that would have been interesting
with the runner moving that was headed
toward right center field
wonderful play by hanson
story owns one of the two hits don't
worry about curveballs and sliders and
all this wacky stuff
oh this ball's hit deep left center
field take a good look
you won't see it for long we've got a
run
trevor story with his fifth of the year
puts the rockies in front
one nothing in the sixth and all five of
the home runs for trevor have been
big home runs two strikes quickly on
rough
one nothing rockies on the story homer
and a strikeout on a slider in the dirt
that's what happens though when you're
working ahead in the count
that's just the second strikeout today
and
that's the first since he struck out the
first battery phase austin slater
trump is hit into two double plays
get on the ground in a base hit sandoval
will stop at second
here comes mauricio dubon second there's
a swing and
dubai hits it a mile to left field way
back there
arios pelota
way up into the bleachers first ball
swinging and the giants have turned this
one around
it's a three run big fly and the giants
have taken a three to one lead
chris owings a walking a strikeout
down the line fair ball
extra bases for oh he's got a hustle
though
good arm safe
run scoring double for chris owings the
rockies down just a run now
so the rockies have pulled topia back
and daniel murphy is going to pinch it
this ball hit the air high deep right
field take a good look
you won't see it for now to run go ahead
pinch it home run from daniel murphy
rocky's up four to three no
doubt about it now here comes charlie
blackmon
this is hit high in the air deep right
field take a good look
you won't see this one for long chuck
nasty
as it went in the second deck and the
rockies now have a three-run lead
well maybe they could turn one yes they
can
just as huey ordered ball game over on a
6-4-3
four double plays turned by the rockies
and they win the ball game six to four